Tony Dungy football night in America
analyst hall-of-famer joining us
Continental Tire coaches corner of
course football night in America and you
have the Eagles and the Cowboys this
Sunday night Tony are you all in on the
Steelers now after what you saw last
night well they still have some things
to work on in my opinion but they're one
of the top teams even early in the year
damn when they were struggling a little
bit up and down I just felt like okay
let this play out they're gonna be there
in November and December and it looks
like they are all right if you still
have this lady on bail situation that
just hangs over this team if I could get
an honest answer out of Mike Tomlin and
I asked him do you want lay beyond bail
back how would he answer that do you
think he would say you know what I want
him back if he wants to be here but if
he is going to come back and be not
getting the long-term contract and he's
not happy with what we're paying and
then he just stay away it kind of
reminds me then and you're old enough to
remember this 1984 the Bears had a very
good defense is just on the cusp they're
two guys Todd Bell and Al Harris were
Pro Bowl players great they were
represented by the same agent they
decided to hold out they weren't happy
with what they got they thought the
Bears couldn't function without him miss
the Super Bowl young two young guys Dave
Duerson and Wilbur Marceau stepped in
they didn't miss a beat those guys
missed the Super Bowl they ended up
buddy Ryan took him to Philadelphia but
you know the train didn't stop and I
think that's what we're seeing here and
maybe I'm Bell's a great player but
James Conner can do a lot of the things
he can do and he's happy to be there so
I think that's where the Steelers are
right now yeah I guess that I I don't
want Le'Veon Bell back just because I
and I know that I can use him and I may
need him if we're gonna win a Super Bowl
but I just don't know like how do you
decide how does he decide how does Mike
Tomlin decide how much is too much as
far as how many touches he gets tone
like if if this is the reason why he's
sitting out how do I do that game by
game quarter by quarter
where he doesn't say hey you know too
many touches here or maybe he has
history tangle the way Connor is playing
he doesn't have to worry about getting
sued I'm giving the ball to James Connor
some I'm throwing in the ball and I
don't feel like there's a big drop-off
so hey later on you come back let's win
a Super Bowl I know you're not making
what what you want to make next year I
hope you ring the bell but let's come
back and win this that's what I'd say so
if if I'm Mike Tomlin and if he says you
know what I'm a little with that I'm not
happy but I'm gonna be a good soldier
and let's go win it then I think they
welcome him back but if he's gonna be
there constantly hey I should make more
money I'm not happy I don't know why
they treated me this way then you don't
want that best team in the AFC right now
is I still like Kansas City I know
they've got some defensive weaknesses
Pittsburgh looked great last night they
played real well the last few weeks I
still see the breakdowns though the
Christian McCaffrey wide open nobody
covered them they've got to eliminate
that and Pittsburgh's got an explosive
offense New England's very balanced but
I'll tell you I still like Kansas City I
really do if you were facing Kansas City
with your defensive background what
would you try to do I would say I got to
make you had those 12 14 play drives
I've gotta someway eliminate those big
gassing plays and it's harder to do than
its sound because they've got so many
guys that can make em and Kareem hunt
can take a screen pass 50 yards it looks
like you know you've got a well played
and all of a sudden he's in the end zone
Travis Kelce can you know make a play
and break a tackle and run by people but
that's what that's how I play them try
to slow them down see if they can be
patient and has those real long time
consuming drives we're talking to Tony
Dungy football night in America analyst
Sunday night on NBC it'll be the Cowboys
in the Eagles how important is this game
let me start with the Cowboys given
everything that's happened here
you know people calling for Jason
Garrett's job is dak Prescott a
franchise quarterback
how important is this and result in
Philadelphia well I think it's huge for
both teams and that's so much long-term
I think Jason Garrett's gonna be there
and no matter what happens
dak Prescott is a good quarterback
they've got to build rebuild the team
around him that they had a couple of
years ago so all that drama and
everything and can forget about that but
if they want to be a playoff team they
have to win in my opinion they had a
home game that they should have won they
felt like they're going to win now
they're three and five you lose another
one and go to three and six it's gonna
be hard to overcome that I want to see
Amari Cooper step up this wise you gave
in my first round
gave up a first-round pick for
Philadelphia doesn't give their corners
much help they leave them on an island
all the time he's got to make some big
plays that's what this offense is
missing can somebody generate that big
play in the passing game and to me it's
got to be Cooper Sunday night does Jon
Gruden have a game plan in Oakland I
don't know I've seen it before and I
know John likes veteran guys he like
offensive guys I think he's saying we
can stockpile these picks and get some
weaponry and get these young players who
are going to be salary cap friendly and
if we draft right you know we're going
to be okay in two years but they to me
they had a pretty good team you know it
wasn't like this was a two and fourteen
team you had a team that was close to
making the playoffs last year's you had
a great player in Kaleo max you've got
good offensive players this offensive
line was as good as Dallas two years ago
now I don't know what's happened to it
and and what he wants but I think they
are building for the future that's the
game plan but those draft choices can be
iffy you know there's no guarantee all
Ryan Leaf was supposed to be a savior
and it didn't turn out to be that way
and we've all seen it
Andre Bruce and you know you can go on
down the line there's no guarantee
because you got three number one draft
choice they're all gonna be great player
do you feel like you won two Super Bowls
I know they know I don't I really don't
I've heard
people say that all the time and I
really don't Jim Mora laid a great
foundation for me in Indianapolis when
when we got there those guys knew how to
work the offense was in place several
the offensive coaches were there Peyton
Manning was there
those guys were more ready to go it took
us a little while to do it but you know
everything is different John put his
system in day one they did a great job
and you have to tip your head to that
and that's what he's trying to do in
Oakland and we'll see what happens
here's a question that we brought up we
had Roger Staubach on in the first hour
and I Paulie said whose career would you
rather have Rodgers or Terry Bradshaw's
I think I'd rather have Terry Bradshaw I
mean Roger was outstanding for a long
time now you get college - you get the
Heisman Trophy - I'm still taking the
fourth Superbowl away okay you know
terry has the ups and down getting best
Roger had some of that too you know
alternating with Craig Morton and
through the quarterback action some of
the injuries and things and he was
tremendous but I think that Terry
Bradshaw going from 70 to 279 and that
10-year stretch went in for Super Bowls
and playing with all those great players
I think I'd take that one and I was
trying to explain this that if you saw
Roger when he played he came in at age
27 but his style of play
could you imagine in him in today where
you have the rpoS here I don't because I
don't remember a quarterback you know
Fran Tarkenton scrambled but Roger beats
you with his legs like he would make you
pay when he scrambled he'd run for a
first down where Fran just was keeping a
play alive I don't know I don't remember
another quarterback who was like that at
that time in the NFL before Roger
Staubach I mean maybe you can help no he
was unique and a tremendous athlete and
that desire in Wilderland but if he had
this type of system where you could
create and where they couldn't really
hit you he would be very hard to deal
with tone good to talk to you have a
good weekend hope the kids are good and
we'll be watching Sunday night all right
thank you buddy
that's a Tony Dungy football night in
America Continental Tire Coaches Corner
Continental Tire proud to be supportive
the Dan Patrick show no matter what you
drive where you drive how you drive
continental as a tire for you
Continental Tire shares your passion for
the game show them your passion by
tweeting your photos to at Continental
Tire for more information visit
Continental Tire dot-com for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]